hello everyone I'm so happy and pleased
to be starting us off and feel very
privileged to be able to be here with
you today to share a little bit about
some very new research that I've been
working on with my research group
research that absolutely would not have
been possible without the support of C
farm I'd like to talk with you today
about conflict in schools and
specifically conflict among adolescents
in secondary schools when you hear the
word conflict you might be thinking
about the term bullying
which is used to mean relationships of
power imbalance in which there is
repeated abuse of one student against
another and that's what I mean by
conflict but I also mean mutual peer
victimization in which two students and
most often their friends as well are
engaged in the cycle of conflict of
teasing of harassment of physical
fighting and I also mean sexual
harassment so my student conflict what
I'm trying to indicate to you is any
kind of behaviors in which students are
making one another feel unwelcome
unaccepted uncomfortable at school and
and self-conscious conflict has and
bullying has been in the media and has
been the talk of public policy circles
quite a bit lately a lot of this is due
to the fact that social media and cell
phone use among students has brought to
the attention adults attention to these
kinds of behaviors whereas previously
they were often hidden from the view of
adults in hallways in bathrooms and so
this has allowed us to renew a
discussion about how to reduce conflict
among students in schools particularly
since we know that conflict is
associated with students staying home
from school more often it's correlated
with depression and with lower
achievement and just in general this is
something that we don't want to come to
characterize our schools in ways that it
has been characterizing schools lately
in particular with a lot of analysts
saying that schools
come to have a climate of conflict but
if we're going to talk about how to
reduce conflict in schools then we need
to talk seriously about what is the
source of that conflict and when parents
and researchers and public policy makers
talk about the sources of conflict they
generally fall within one of two camps
on this thinking about what is the
source of conflict and I would say the
first camp says that when we observe
conflict we think that it's because of
the way that students have been raised
or because of the ways that students
have been taught and so in order to
reduce it we need to work on students
character we need to teach them skills
like empathy another camp would say well
it's not really as much about the
individual students as much as it is
about their entire society we have
commentators saying that we live today
in a bullying Society and that our
schools are little microcosms of that
and the climate itself involves
everything from the administrative
structure of the school the physical
structure of the school the rules and
then the greater society all around that
our laws are anti-discrimination laws
and so forth so what do we make of these
different explanations well
psychological research and I'm a social
psychologist would discourage us I think
from putting too much weight on the
character of individual kids there's
some research that shows that students
don't enjoy the conflict but they don't
support it but they often feel as though
they can't argue against it they can't
stand up against it and they fear that
they'll be punished by their peers
ostracized for being what we have often
urged them to be which is an active
bystander other research shows that
these kids fears are born out and so in
studies where students are asked to
judge active bystanders they often say
that they like these students less than
the students who haven't spoken out in
these kinds of scenarios that they're
faced with so what about the the climate
hypothesis the research that I just
described you suggest that there's
something more to what we would call
students expectations of conflicts and
so where are they getting these
expectations and this is the where the
other camp says well they're getting
these expectations from teachers and
from the way the school was set up and
from our laws and our rules in their
immediate environment
this makes sense there's got to be some
truth to it and as a social psychologist
we believe that there's an interaction
between the individual their character
their values and the social environment
in which they find themselves but
there's also a problem with just
stopping at this analysis of it's the
climate there's three reasons at least
why this could be problematic one is
that when we say climate we're pointed
to do so many different kinds of factors
we're pointing to the the rules of the
school and the administration and the
teachers and the students the second is
that the word climate itself
communicates something about our
assumptions about change we use we
invoke the word climate we invoke the
word culture when we're trying to
describe something that is deeply
entrenched slow that is evolved over
time and our schools right now are
struggling with these two assumptions
one that they need to tackle all of
these different factors and two that
it's going to take a lot of time I want
to suggest a third reason why just
stopping it this analysis of climate is
problematic because it implies that it's
the adults who need to be the ones to
act adults are the ones who control the
rules who control the administration who
control the media and this really
disempowers students in this equation
it's not students who are really part of
this solution and what I'd like to argue
to you today is that the theories that
we're working on in identity and in
perceptions of social standards and
identity groups would suggest that
there's a third way to look at this
problem and specifically I'd like to
draw your attention more to the idea
that student behavior is caused by their
perceptions of social standards at the
school and these perceptions these
psychological psychologically generated
ideas are much more malleable than these
larger scale climate factors like laws
and administrations and and schools
physical structures specifically what
we'd like to suggest is that students
are constantly observing one another in
their environments they're observing one
another's behavior and the behavior of
other students to whom they're connected
whom they are observing give them ideas
about what is normal in a situation and
what's even desirable so for example
when students observe someone posting an
egg
comment on the social media site this
gives them the idea that this is a
common thing to do this is a typical
thing to do likewise when they observe a
student being ostracized by other
students for reporting to a teacher
something distressing that's going on
they observe that it's undesirable to be
reporting these kinds of behaviors so in
other words social psychologists call
these ideas perceived norms these kinds
of ideas about social standards are
driving students behavior they're
driving students behavior because
they're trying to live up to the
expectations of their social group so
what you'll see in a lot of these
discussions about school climate is that
people will urge teachers to communicate
social standards to students they'll put
this onus on teachers and that is a very
important factor but it can't be the
only thing because what we know about
social identities and social groups is
that students have to maintain their
reputation and maintain their status by
living up to the expectations of their
peers and if their peers behavior is can
is communicating this idea that
participating in conflicts is a way to
maintain your reputation then they're
going to be motivated to do this as
socially savvy beings not as individuals
without empathy or who need some kind of
character education so we've been
working on this idea with my research
group and specifically the idea that
there might be certain students in a
school who are more powerful when it
comes to setting social standards of
that school we're very interested in the
idea that perhaps you don't need to
address every single student in the
school but perhaps some of them and we
try to find these by using social
network analysis perhaps some of them
might be quite powerful in shaping their
peers expectations for what behaviors
are typical what behaviors are desirable
as a way of gaining insight and how to
reset these standards towards standards
that are much more tolerant and
accepting of lots of different types of
students with my colleague Hannes
Shepard we've been doing some studies in
which we ask students who have you spent
time with in the last week either online
or face-to-face and we use their
responses to these questions to build a
social network like this one where you
see that all of the gray
circles there are students at the school
the yellow colored circles are students
who we like to call social reference
social reference are the students who we
think might have a powerful influence
over shaping students expectations of
what is normal and desirable at their
school we've identified at least two
different kinds of social reference we
call them the widely known and the
clique leaders and as you can see the
young girl who's at the center of both
of these fictionalized depictions of
what it would look like if you zoomed in
on them in this social network show that
widely known students have connections
to students all across the social
network so many in fact that not all of
these students are even connected to one
another these students aren't
necessarily popular but they do have a
status in which students know these are
people who a lot of people know who a
lot of people look at in our school the
clique leaders on the other hand are at
the center of social groups that may not
be as mainstream oftentimes the word
clique is associated with popularity but
here what we mean is that these students
may stick to themselves in the school
these students are often also not as
much notice by teachers when it comes to
choosing student leaders for change
efforts at a school what's important
about reaching out to these clique
leaders as well as to the widely known
students is that cliques are very
well-known for defining their identity
as against the mainstream of the school
so if you wanted to reach out to the
widest number of students at the school
you'd want to reach out to these
students as well to their leaders to try
to convince them that yes we are also
participating in these new standards so
how would we go about testing this idea
that social reference can spread a new
ideas about social standards of behavior
and behavior itself being behavioral
scientists we didn't experiment
we went into a high school and we
measured their social network as I just
described to you earlier and we
identified the students were widely
known the students were clique leaders
and we randomly selected some of them to
participate in a year-long campaign
against conflict at the school others
who weren't select
did simply didn't participate in the
program there was no intervention for
these students and what we did is over
time over the course of the year as
students participated in this campaign
by associating their faces with slogans
that they had designed to try to reduce
these kinds of behaviors at their school
at the end of the school year we tracked
the students who were connected to these
social reference verses the students who
were connected to the social reference
who had not participated and the bottom
line is that we find that they in fact
are very influential over the people to
whom they are connected so when we asked
students at the end of the year whether
it's normal to start drama at their
school starting drama is their way of
talking about bullying for example one
way of talking about bullying at this
school students who have been connected
to these these social reference were
significantly less likely to say that it
was normal they also communicated other
kinds of social standards for example
it's okay to ignore rumors they were
much more likely to say this if they
were connected in the network to one of
these students but it wasn't just their
perceptions it was also their behavior
that changed so we gathered
administrative data at the school about
whether these students had been
disciplined for peer conflict we
surveyed teachers in separate surveys to
ask them are these students contributing
to a negative environment and turned out
that those who were connected to these
social referenced their behavior was
also likely to change they were less
likely to be nominated by teachers for
bad behavior more likely to be nominated
as students who would even defend others
from harassment so what this shows us is
that social reference can have a
powerful influence on the students to
whom they are connected but the question
is did they have an effect on the
climate the entire climate of the school
and that's something that we couldn't
answer with this research what we needed
to do is to be able to compare this
school in which we were intervening to a
school in which we weren't present the
program wasn't there at all and with the
support of C far this is it in fact what
we did this year we went into 656
different middle schools in New Jersey
and measured the networks of every
single school which involved 24,000
children we then went into half of these
schools randomly selected and conducted
a program in which we invited their
schools social reference students to
participate in another campaign against
conflict at their school another twist
that we that we used in this particular
experiment is that we invited varying
amounts of non social reference to also
participate in in the program so that we
could test not just can social reference
change the conflict the the climate of
conflict at their entire school overall
levels and patterns of student conflict
but are they necessary can other
students do this as well what is their
contribution so first what they did all
of these students was decide what they
did in fact want to change about their
school and our program was called the
routes program I mentioned this just
because it's an important point again
about student social identity many
interventions will ask students to
repeat phrases about conflict that are
that have been delivered to them by
adults and what we thought was that the
messages about social standards would be
much more authentic if they were coming
from students who had decided for
themselves
what is it that we really want to change
what's going on at our school and these
are some examples of things that
students brought up as things that they
would like to change about their school
some of you some of them you might
recognize as classic stories of bullying
that adults talk about in the media but
many of them were not but still they
were valid they were of concern to these
students they were causing them distress
from there where the students did was
launch their own campaign they had lots
of different strategies for doing so
including designing slogans and signing
their names to it again to make very
salient that they were the ones who were
promoting this kind of new social
standard they gave out wristbands with
some of the slogan words on them when
they recognized someone at their school
doing something good as a reward and as
an extra motivation so what did we find
well first of all they were extremely
successful at getting students at their
schools to talk about conflict and what
you see in this graph is just a higher
level overall independent of how many
social references were part of the group
and getting to people at the school to
talk
conflicts compared again to the schools
where we weren't doing this intervention
program but here's a critical graph at
each school we also gathered
disciplinary data to ask how much
overall peer conflict was there at the
school we these are data actually from
the school's administrative records and
what you see here is that again there is
an effect of having this intervention at
your school there was lower overall peer
conflicts in such a way that you could
maybe suggest that this was an entire
climate change this effect size is
equivalent to every single student in an
intervention school having one less
incident of getting pulled into the
office for conflicts over the course of
the school year but well you also notice
about this graph is that the difference
between intervention and treatment and
the intervention and the no intervention
schools grows the more social reference
you add to the group so the social
reference are the ones who are driving
in part this behavioral change having
more of them having at least a quarter
of them is what leads to this kind of
overall school change so I'd like to end
there and and say that for one I think
that one emerging lesson from this
research which is still ongoing is a
very exciting one which suggests that
its students themselves who can be
involved in setting the standards of a
school climate note that we did nothing
to change some of the larger factors of
climate over the course of this study we
didn't train the teachers we didn't
change the administrative structure or
any of the rules this was all due to
student changed behavior over the course
of of the year the other thing I want to
point out is that what this what this
research suggests it redirects our
attention from these larger scale
factors of a school to more subtle
factors of social perception and social
identity these are in fact what we would
like to suggest the cult the sort of
psychological underpinnings of culture
how we understand the social standards
of our environment another exciting
thing is that while we can identify
certain social reference in a group who
can make these changes it wasn't
necessarily an elite
task force of social reference students
who accomplish these kinds of
large-scale behavioral change at their
schools the most the the highest
proportion of social reference in these
intervention groups at the schools was a
third so in fact what these students did
was build an alliance of students who
were willing to help who were not
necessarily at the center of their
social networks along with students who
were in fact some of the more salient
leaders of their school so I'd like to
leave you with those thoughts and to say
finally that this kind of research
doesn't disregard the importance of
large scale factors but it does redirect
our attention to some of the ways in
which social identity and social
perceptions can change these large
scales of climates of culture in our
schools and and perhaps elsewhere thank
you
you